peggy 18.
hi i'm martin capel game director for
assassin's creed rogue
and today we'll be taking a look at some
of the new templar gameplay in action
in this video we will meet shea patrick
cormack an assassin turned templar who
vows to bring down the brotherhood in
the new world and see him in action
using a range of new weapons tools and
tactics to hunt down an assassin and
capture a gang headquarters
this is the river valley our brand new
location that provides the first truly
hybrid gameplay bringing naval and land
together in one seamless world and
experience
the river valley is set in the american
interior where the colonial forces of
britain and france fought through
supremacy during the seven years war and
the waterways were a lifeline for both
nations
shea's ship the morrigan is equipped
with the most advanced weaponry for its
day
first of all we see the carinaes front
cannons that fire explosive shots able
to damage and stun enemy ships
then we move in to finish off our
opponents with the ram
besides its weaponry the morrigan is
also faster and more maneuverable than
the jackdaw from assassin's creed iv
allowing you to turn tighter and avoid
enemy fire more efficiently
the morrigan also features puzzle guns
18th century machine guns that you can
use in free aim mode to target weak
spots and engage smaller ships with
deadly effect
and if you find yourself being chased
then you can use another templar tactic
the burning oil barrels
they slow down enemy ships and deal a
great amount of damage
with the enemy ships destroyed we can
now proceed with taking over the gang
headquarters as you can see from the
mini-map the area is shaded in orange
this indicates that the headquarters in
the area surrounding it are controlled
by gangs loyal to the assassins a
collection of lawless criminals and
privateers who fight the colonial powers
for dominance in the new world
as you step ashore you will see the
objectives you need to complete to take
control of the headquarters to destroy
the barrels of poison gas to cut down
the assassin flag and to kill the gang
leader the assassin
shea's new arsenal includes an air rifle
and grenade launcher the grenade
launcher uses a range of area effect
ammunition types such as the sleep
grenade while the air rifle offers more
precision
as you move through the trees you can
hear whispers in the background this is
shae's eagle sense telling him there is
a stalker nearby stalkers are masters of
ambush who can hide and even launch
their assassinations against you
but shea is able to turn the tables on
his opponent
in rogue we encourage players to use all
the tools at their disposal to
manipulate people and to create
confusion and diversion
so now we are moving in on the first of
our objectives a barrel of poison gas
shae climbs the building to shoot the
gunner with a sleep dart
then moves across to neutralize him
using a firecracker dart shae splits the
barrel spilling its contents and
affecting those people closest to it
moving on to the next barrel this time
we will get in close for rogue we have
improved the navigation making it easier
to access high places and to move around
freely and fluidly
as the brow breaks shea uses his gas
mask to protect himself
the gas mask is proof against smoke
bombs and all other poisons provided
you're equipping time
moving into the heart of the gang
headquarters let's destroy the third and
final world to complete our first
objective
again shea uses a firecracker dart to
destroy the barrel this time you can see
a prisoner being affected by the gas and
join in the fight
an injured guard using a smoke bomb and
guards coming in to attack the berserked
enemies and becoming berserk themselves
with the poison barrels destroyed let's
move on
our next target is the assassin these
are the most effective enemies in rogue
switching on eagle vision we can see
that it is nearby so let's proceed with
caution
the assassin delivers a devastating
strike and throws a smoke bomb to
disorientate shay but shea uses his gas
mask to negate the effects of the smoke
and gives chase
the assassin shoots shay and calls him
reinforcements to his aid
using one of his enemies as a shield
against the gunner shea deals with these
guards and resumes the hunt for the
assassin
the compass in eagle vision shows us
that the assassin is behind this
building
so going up high we can launch another
attack
this time the assassin uses smoke to try
and stun you while he and his men attack
but with his guards defeated the
assassin flees again
in his attempt to kill you the assassin
is even able to use the environment
against you such as shooting barrels of
gunpowder
finally shea takes to the rooftops to
chase the assassin down
and succeeds in eliminating him using an
air assassination
with the assassin neutralized the final
objective is to tear down the symbol of
gang control their flag
as he throws the flag onto the fire shae
completes his conquest of the gang
headquarters
we hope you've enjoyed this latest
glimpse into assassin's creed rogue and
we look forward to you joining us and
shae in his epic adventure
you